today maybe already has happened Donald
Trump will be arrested and charged with
what we have now learned will be 34
felony counts but an exclusive Yahoo
news report by Michael isikoff the chief
investigative correspondent doing really
good work at Yahoo news said there will
be no handcuffs and there will be no mug
shot in special treatment for the failed
former president Donald Trump this is
historic stuff we are living through a
remarkable event
Michael isikoff writes as the article
just disappeared Donald Trump will be
placed under arrest Tuesday and informed
he has been charged with 34 felony
counts for falsification of business
records according to a source brief on
the procedures a New York City Police
arrest report summarizing the charges
against Trump will be prepared and
entered into the court system Trump will
be led into the courtroom and formerly
formally arraigned on the charges none
of which are misdemeanors remember the
right-wingers were saying these are all
misdemeanors all misdemeanors well maybe
there's one felony these are reportedly
all felonies but Trump will be given
special treatment he will not be put in
handcuffs he will not be placed in a
jail cell what a dream that would be and
he will not be subjected to a mug shot
even most white-collar defendants
are
um subject to those three elements the
Manhattan District Attorney's office has
been Consulting with secret service in
New York City Court officials said
there's no reason to give him a mug shot
there's no reason to put them in
handcuffs the stated reason for
handcuffing is defendants might be a
flight risk or a threat to the D.A or
Court Personnel neither are judged to be
relevant for former president Trump
given that he will be protected by
Secret Service agents at all times at
all times
um this is going to be
an incredible event an incredible event
we will be live we were live again the
timing of recording today is a little
bit complicated for what is taking place
there will be still photos in the
courtroom there will not be video
cameras in the courtroom and this was
another subject of much controversy as I
said I can't think of any trial
proceedings any Court proceedings rather
more relevant to the public interest
than the arraignment of a former
president for which there should be
cameras live video cameras but there
will not be
sort of jokingly do you think that this
proceeding will finally give us Trump's
real height and weight which he's been
lying about for a long time claiming to
be 6'3 and 239 probably not and that's
sort of a joke that's not really
important we are going to now see over
the next 24 hours and I hope everybody
is prepared for it we are going to see
the worst of the worst of Maga trumpism
I'm going to make a small adjustment
here to my audio uh we are going to see
the absolute worst Faith takes this
isn't Justice no no no no no it is
Justice to learn and realize that even a
former president is not above the law
these are politically motivated charges
you haven't even seen the charges and
you're not aware of the evidence how
could you possibly make that claim at
this time
This Is Never Done where you use
testimony from a lawyer because it's
protected well what about the crime
fraud exception which we're going to
talk about later and by the way we don't
yet know how it worked out but Marjorie
Taylor green leading a protest in New
York City quite literally as we are
recording by tomorrow I'm sure I will
have more information for you about how
that turns out so we will follow all of
it we will report on it I hope you will
join me live and in the meantime Donald
Trump's final 24 hours before his arrest
indicating that he is absolutely
terrified one of our sponsors today is
fume not everything in a bad habit is
wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad part from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning device that
does exactly that fume is not electronic
there's no Vapor or harmful chemicals
fume is just a delicious flavored air
that makes replacing your bad habit easy
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable Parts which is great for
fidgeting which can be great for people
breaking bad habits look at what people
online are saying they weren't sure what
to expect but ended up loving the taste
and the feel stopping is something lots
of people put off because it's difficult
to do but switching to fume is easy and
enjoyable there's no reason that you
can't be the next fume success story
head on over to trifum.com and use the
code Pacman to save 10 when you get the
journey pack which comes with the device
and three flavors the link is down below